let's get into this here's a white guy
that has a problem let's hear it Carter
here's some guy in recovery this Nick
Carter Carter I don't believe that
Carter from Marysville Marysville
Washington yo King in the sting part of
football season I came up with a good
debate for you guys to try who do you
think would be the better quarterback
Chris dance D'Elia or Andrew cheeto
Santino I think and you know the redhead
might be a better quarterback in NFL but
so younger to be a good debate for you
guys so uh Gang Gang rub-a-dub buzz buzz
thanks guys
dang bro I'm gonna eat this isn't this
one for me he's easy
cheater Santino the ginger to remember
dude you know what I'm saying the
[ __ ] red Andy Dalton bro I think
you'd he's got more fire in him he
doesn't care what happens to him he has
seen more sports Chris doesn't like
sports Chris doesn't like he doesn't
watch doing anything or sports so but I
think Chris more athletic now what do
you mean by athletic looks athletic or
actually as athletic man and what type
of athleticism if you're talking about
somebody just swim romantically to the
bottom of a [ __ ] beautiful like ocean
area and pick up a [ __ ] conch shell
okay Chris okay if you're talking about
somebody to [ __ ] sidestep a couple of
[ __ ] crackheads in an alley somewhere
Santa and [ __ ] run the ball to the
end zone losing both of his arms in the
process and I don't care and not caring
not even get it to the end zone
yeah Santino Santino did grow up in
Chicago the streets of Chicago as a
redhead yeah and yeah he's a
consideration he has some darkness about
him okay anger there um just cause he's
redhead I've met some pretty chill
redheads yeah and you know not chill
redhead yeah that's true he is a podcast
about alcoholism look I think this is an
easy one for me man this is Santino if
you're talking about if your sport is
someone to lay on a cloud and finish a
[ __ ] pudding that they're not gonna
lie
with their shirt off not only feeding
some pudding to themselves but feeding
something to each nipple on their chest
lilia okay your sport is [ __ ]
wrestling a needle out of some [ __ ]
business man's arm some shady [ __ ]
jewelry ice well that's not football and
do it linebacker a shady businessman
with a needle whatever and doing a line
of coke and a Kia Sephia as he [ __ ]
argues with his [ __ ] wife over
FaceTime about their two [ __ ] fat
kids somewhere auntie no yeah I got a
great man this is a easy one sadena all
day you know yeah you know what 55%
Santino's pretty close interesting
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]